>> THE VICE PRESIDENT CAN ALWAYS
COUNT ON HER DEFENDERS IN THE
MEDIA.
THIS TIME "WASHINGTON POST"
COLUMNIST EUGENE ROBINSON CAME
TO THE RESCUE AFTER HE WAS ASKED
ABOUT KAMALA HARRIS' VIABILITY
AS A PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
DURING THAT Q&A WITH READERS,
ROBINSON RESPONDED, QUOTE, IF
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS IS NOT
HAVING AN IMPACT, IT IS MOSTLY
PERHAPS ENTIRELY BECAUSE SHE'S
IN THE GUILDED PRISON KNOWN AS
THE VICE PRESIDENCY.
SHE'S A MUCH BETTER AND
EFFECTIVE POLITICIAN THAN HER
CURRENT POSITION ALLOWS HER TO
DEMONSTRATE.
SHE WILL BE A FORMIDABLE
CONTENDER FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL NOMINATION.
APPARENTLY IT WAS OPPOSITE DAY,
TODD, BECAUSE I CAN'T THINK OF A
MORE HYPERBOLIC ENTIRELY WRONG
STATEMENT, BECAUSE, LET'S BE
SPECIFIC ABOUT THIS, VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS HAS MULTIPLE
JOBS ACTUALLY.
THE VICE PRESIDENCY ISN'T A
GUILDED PRISON.
IT IS AN HONOR TO SERVE AT THE
PLEASURE OF THE PEOPLE OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA IN THAT
ROLE, AND INCLUDING ONE OF HER
TITLES, WHICH IS SOUTHERN BORDER
CZAR.
SHE ACTUALLY HAS A WIDE
POTENTIAL TO SHOW US EXACTLY THE
KIND OF LEADERSHIP THAT SHE IS,
WHICH I GUESS WE'VE LEARNED SHE
IS NOT.
>> POINT BEAUTIFULLY WELL TAKEN.
I'LL JUST ADD THIS ARTICLE IS
CLEARLY LAUNDRYING OF KAMALA
HARRIS FOR 2024.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT JOE IS GOING
TO DO YET, BUT IF IT'S NOT JOE
KAMALA HARRIS IS GOING TO BE ONE
OF THE PEOPLE ON THE LIST.
THEY GOT TO MAKE HER LOOK GOOD,
AND THAT REQUIRES A MAJOR
LAUNDRYING OR RESUSCITATION
EFFORT.
IT'S TRUE, IT'S A THANKLESS JOB,
WE NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT, BUT
ALL OTHER VPs HAVE DONE THE
JOB AND HELD SERVE.
EVERY TIME KAMALA HARRIS OPENS
HER MOUTH IT'S A WORD SALAD.
THAT'S WHY EVERY TIME SHE OPENS
HER MOUTH SHE LOSES A POINT.
SPARE ME THE MISOGYNY AND RACISM
THING.
WE ATTACK JOE BIDEN FOR NOT ABLE
TO STRING SENTENCES TOGETHER,
AND HE'S WHITE AND MALE AS THEY
COME.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
KENNEDY, HERE'S THE THING, TOO,
THE QUESTION, SHE SAID ASSUMING
BIDEN RUNS AGAIN, WOULDN'T IT
MAKE SENSE TO DROP VP HARRIS AND
FIND ANOTHER RUNNING PARTNER,
BECAUSE SHE STRIKES ME AS HAVING
LITTLE IMPACT, NOT AN INSPIRING
LEADER, AND THERE ARE NUMEROUS
HIGH-PROFILE DEMS, CREATING MORE
ENTHUSIASM FOR THE TICKET.
>> MIKE PENCE DID A LOT IN TERMS
OF VACCINES DURING THE PANDEMIC.
YOU KNOW, HE WAS TASKEDDED WITH
A VERY, VERY BIG JOB,
ESSENTIALLY COORDINATING THE
PANDEMIC COUNTER EFFORT.
HE DID THAT VERY WELL.
YOU KNOW, LET'S GO TO ANOTHER
LOSER, VICE PRESIDENT DAN
QUAYLE.
>> HA-HA-HA!
>> ALSO A VERY EFFECTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT.
AND ASCENDED TO THE PRESIDENCY,
AND PROBABLY WOULD HAVE BEEN A
TWO-TERMER IF IT WEREN'T FOR
ROSS PEROT.
AS A COMMUNICATOR AND A LEADER,
SHE'S FARED WORSE.
NOT BECAUSE IT'S A GUILDED
PRISON, YOU KNOW.
IT'S, LIKE, WOW, WHAT A LOVELY
FLORID PHRASE, BUT IT DOESN'T
CAPTURE HER INEPTITUDE.
>> IF I WAS IN HER SHOES, I'D BE
FURIOUS, BECAUSE SHE'S
MARGINALIZED HER TO A VICTIM WHO
CAN'T DEFEND HERSELF.
WHY WOULD ANYONE WANT TO BELIEVE
SHE COULD DEFEND THE COUNTRY?
LIKE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SHE'S SAYING SHE'S IN PRISON
BECAUSE SHE CAN'T GET POLICY
DONE THAT WOULD WORK, LIKE THE
GUY IN THE WHITE HOUSE NOW.
THAT GOES BEYOND DEFENSE.
SHE CHANGES STAFF THE WAY MOST
OF US CHANGE SHOES.
OR IS THAT MY OWN?
I LOVE SHOES.
>> WITH KAMALA HARRIS, ARE YOU
GOING TO BE AN EMPOWERED
POWERFUL WOMAN OR LET PEOPLE
MAKE EXCUSES FOR YOU AND TURN
YOU INTO A VICTIM?
HOW DO YOU SELL THAT WHEN LAST
TIME WHEN PEOPLE THOUGHT YOU
WERE POWERFUL AND EMPOWERED YOU
ONLY GOT ONE DELEGATE.
DID SHE EVEN GET ONE?
YEAH, SHE DIDN'T EVEN GET ONE.
>> WASN'T IT ELEANOR ROOSEVELT
WHO IS A VICTIM IS YOURSELF.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE INEPTITUDE,
THE HALLMARK OF HER SERVICE
SINCE SHE BEGAN, WHICH WHY IT'S
SO MIND BOG LICK WHY THE MEDIA
CONTINUE TO PROP HER UP.
IT SHOWS ON THE COVER OF "VOGUE"
AND "ELLE" AND "LOS ANGELES
TIMES" SHE'S BEEN WORSHIPED BY
THE MEDIA.
THIS LATEST EXCLAMATION BY THE
WAPO COLUMNIST IS A CHERRY ON
TOP OF AN APOLOGIST MEDIA THAT
REFUSES TO SEE THE REALITY MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ARTICULATED OF
HER UTTER INCOMPETENCE AND
FAILURE AT ANY ATTEMPT AT
LEADERSHIP.
>> SHE'S THE DEFINITION, THE
PICTURE IN THE DICTIONARY, OF
FAILING, BECAUSE EVERYONE HAS
PROPPED HER UP, PUT HER IN
LIGHT, GIVEN HER GREAT KUDOS FOR
HER COOL CONVERSES, ALL THAT.
AS YOU POINTED OUT, THE VOTERS
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO CHOOSE
HER.
THEY REJECTED HER.
THEY WERE FOR THE IMPRESSED BY
HER.
THEY WERE NOT MOVED BY HER.
THEY DIDN'T FEEL SHE WAS UP TO
THE TASK.
I LOVE THAT EVERYBODY IS BENDING
OVER BACKWARDS, NO, NO, SHE'S
THE FUTURE, AND THE VOTERS ARE,
LIKE, NO.
>> SHE WAS THE AG OF CALIFORNIA.
IF SHE CAN'T CONVINCE YOU OF HER
SKILL SET, WHO COULD SHE HIRE
THAT COULD DO A BETTER JOB THAN
AN ATTORNEY GENERAL?
>> ALSO A U.S. SENATOR.
SHE SHOULD HAVE COLLEAGUES IN
CONGRESS WHO CAN HELP HER
MOVE --
>> YOU MEAN FRIENDS?
>> YES, THAT WOULD POTENTIALLY
MAKE THE COUNTRY, PARTICULARLY
IMMIGRATION, BETTER.
INTERESTING THE SILENCE IS
DEAFENING.
REMEMBER, WHAT MADE